Although published in 1989, this book is relevant today more than ever...
...because the business world is becoming more accepting of humanist concepts.
The author's values are in strong contrast with the process-based beliefs of the past.
Stephen Covey's seven habits start with the importance of controlling one's environment,...
...self-determination and choice,...
...and the habit of personal leadership,...
...leading yourself toward your goals.
When habit two is the mental creation of goals,...
...habit three is the physical part.
With habit four, Covey talks about interpersonal leadership...
...and how achievements are determined by successful cooperation with others.
Habit five is entitled "Seek first to understand and then to be understood."
Here, he talks about the essence of developing and maintaining positive affiliations in all aspects of life.
Habit six covers synergy,...
...while the last habit concerns the habit of self-renewal and spiritual, mental, physical, social, and emotional growth.